former columbus ohio police officer is
now charged with murder for killing a
black man back in december adam coye was
responding to a non-emergency call when
he encountered andre hill
inside a friend's garage police say the
shooting happened within seconds and coy
failed to activate his body camera or
give
any medical aid hill was left lying
alone on the ground for several minutes
the footage you're looking at here from
the scene was recovered later only after
the fact
coy's lawyer says the former officer
will plead not guilty ohio's attorney
general says grand jury
the grand jury found clear evidence of
wrongdoing and the hill family's lawyer
says they are
cautiously optimistic truth
is the best friend of justice and the
grand jury here found the truth
andre hill should not be dead that does
not necessarily mean
there will be a conviction so they
understand that this is going to be a
long journey to justice
this week the columbus city council
passed andre's law
allowing criminal charges if a columbus
police officer fails to turn on a body
camera or
call for medical help when necessary so
this is obviously an example of a city
that is taking
fairly swift action it's interesting
that the only reason any footage exists
of this incident is because there was a
pre-roll technology on the camera so
although the officer did not turn it on
himself
the camera was rolling for 60 seconds
prior yeah which is why we have that
video yeah
it is you got to figure out a way to
make these cameras roll
uh continuously continuously i don't
think it's good that the officer gets to
determine
when it goes on and when it goes off in
this case it's good they have the
pre-roll
and it's unclear whether the officer
knew that pre-roll role was there but if
we did not have it we wouldn't be having
this conversation
right in all likelihood as ben crum said
a conviction is not
guaranteed here but this is a good first
step for the whole family
in their in their quest for just same
rules for everybody in that case you're
right about that tony